holy [ __ ] okay that looked awesome well
yeah it looks pretty good yeah can i say
i'm gonna start because because okay i'm
going to say something negative to start
and then and then I don't want you to
talk yet can I just say for the next for
the next thing that you show Ubisoft do
turn down the damn bloom on the thing
because cheese that all I saw my game is
half of everything just looked
completely washed out from from
whiteness okay so come on get a grip
otherwise lighting now now now moving to
the positive elevating on is Alexa area
yes so I actually I saw syndicate last
week I went to Quebec City not a chance
to see it in the studio and meet the
people making it and I'm I'm really
optimistic I really like what I saw I'm
one of the big things that I really like
and I think people will really like and
they show during the gameplay demo is
those vehicles you can hijack vehicles
like GTA style punch people out take
their horse and carriage and like run
over people in the streets I really like
it and if you notice the people on the
sidewalks will react like if you run
them over they'll fall down and people
really go [ __ ] and to like move away
we're suddenly watching this thing you
know it's gtas essence Capri it looks
really good I I think this is going to
be I can't wait for like the YouTube
let's play videos of people like
flipping carriages and crashing them you
can crash carriages to cause diversions
the developers also told me there will
be trains and boats in some capacity you
actually see concept art in their
developer diary of Jacob fighting on a
train which is a moving train which is
super cool I saw the I saw Jacob
fighting on top of these carriages I saw
him jumping at one point I jumped on top
of the big demo I was watching and
Quebec the guy jumped on the back of a
carriage and a police officer jumped up
after me and like threw me off it was
for me I me I wasn't playing through the
driver off it was super cool i'm really
excited can you tell i'm like a little
your side like watching that it makes it
makes the the carriage uh chase actual
look pretty interesting would be the
first carriage chase in assassin's creed
this is appeared before and actually
um previous carriage chases haven't been
the strongest su of other assassins
creed games but what I like about that
is it looked it looked like you know it
it's it's it's supposed to be a little
bit clumsy right it's it's this big
thing with like a you know the wagon in
the back tipping and you know it's
courses and stuff so you can expect it
to be perfectly I like you know TWiki or
whatever I'm making up words now some
new worried you know thankee oh it
looked really fun I'm warrant [ __ ] like
the combat 2 i'm kind of curious like
you saw the comp iphone a combat there
it looks really fast-paced one thing
that that i saw and i don't know how i
represented this is the whole but in the
in like in the gang fight we saw like
one gank a game yes but in that in that
in the bit that we saw one thing that
really intrigued me was the fact that
you didn't see like a horde of dudes
surrounding him right then it becomes
like a an ultra choreographed thing
where everybody's all waiting around to
attack and well until the moment now i
don't know if that's partially because
of the way it's set up he's only taking
on one attacker at a time because
everybody else is busy so the thing
about the gang fights I did I saw the
gang fights in like this when I went
inside the game and it you run in with
your dudes you run into the gang fight
and not all of them go after you like
the opposing AI the the people on the
opposing gang will go after other people
in your gang like everyone is not
focused on you so it feels like a gang
fight and as Jacob or whoever you're
playing as you can go around and say
alright I'm going to take out this guy
I'm going to stab this one I'm going to
stun this person like you are part of a
group fight it's not a group of people
and you and the group of people are
focused on you while everyone else tries
to fend them off like it's a true gang
fight and i love the gang fights like
that looks really cool they block off
the city streets you see people cheering
on the sides like it's really cool when
you saw it i mean when you talk to them
do they mention that that was like a
pretty typical scenario in the game like
is that a lot of the combats gonna play
out so that it's not like a bunch of
dudes and then everything just everybody
happening to wait until you know you're
you're in a position to actually you
know hey
they talked about retooling the AI to be
more responsive re gang fights gang
fights will be like that and and there's
a gang fight you have a gang fight is
how you get control of a borough like
you were in a gang fight because you had
to take out bloody Nora and take out her
game so ter gang so that will be
something that you're doing a lot of the
gang fights will be a lot of them as far
as combat goes yes and what I saw what I
saw but we were sort of sneaking around
and taking people out and alleys and
whatnot people won't won't wait around
for you like the AI doesn't wait around
for you they'll pull out their gun
they'll run after you I didn't see any
any AI that I was in combat with
standing still another thing about the
combat is it's all close quarters so
right all brawling like you're in 1868
London your criminal underground unless
you're doing something like that where
you're sneaking around but um let's
let's actually talk about this for a
second they changed the stealth it's no
longer cover-based like you you're not
you're not going to be focusing on
blending in with crowds or hiding out in
bushes or sneaking or just hiding it's
not hiding base is basically just a
stealth yes yeah its stealth it's a more
modern stealth like you'll be crouching
you hit a button a crouch and you sneak
around sort of yeah sort of soft snap
into the cover when you get close to it
and you can do nothing yeah and you can
use like the throwing knives work
differently now you have hallucinogenic
darts so you can actually throw them
into fire sources and it'll puff out and
it'll make the enemies around that fire
source kill each other and as we saw
just here you can use the throwing
knives to knock things down that are
hanging in the sky like they're not just
for killing anymore which is really cool
also the whistles back you can Crouch
around a corner and whistle and someone
will come towards you and you can just
pull them into cover and pull them
behind whatever you wherever you are and
just stab them and what would Assassin's
Creed be without a bale of hay right
really these kids are like uh because he
look everyone is reacting to you do you
notice this yeah all those people
they're like oh like that were like oh
like me and the guys come around like a
new not going over there see this guy
here you little he's screwed look at
these mustaches a plus on the mustaches
and the facial
Aaron said to get ya lots lots of good
facial hair I would actually like I'm
kind of glad I was going to shave this
morning just trim up my beer and I'm
like I'm glad you kept it no I know I'm
kind of bushy look at that was the game
this woman didn't stand a chance look at
her bye and she's our ally hooray she
good nice tip of the hat top of the
morning I got a lot govna sorry speaking
speaking of which you know I think I I'd
love to see about more of them I mean we
don't really know a whole lot we know
about the you know the characters now
and of course I don't want to talk about
Ed some who I didn't want to talk about
you mom but I one thing I'm curious
about is like where the story is going
to go and things like that i mean i
think that you have a preview going up i
do 930 should be up now actually um we
saw we were told that the story for
Assassin's Creed syndicate you have EV
and Jacob and even Jacob have been bored
born outside of London and you will be
experiencing London for the first time
along with the twins they're twins I
really like the dynamic here she's
sitting up he's hunched over I like
their banter you actually there will be
story missions where you can actually
pick who you play as but both of them
will also have story missions specific
to them now Evie we're told we're going
to get more information on her a little
later this summer she's going to get her
own time to shine in the media spotlight
I suppose but right now they are showing
off Jacob so we will definitely be
getting more from her but I really like
her i like the little freckles on her
face I like that they're a brother and
sister something that I something that I
didn't like about unity is I think the
romance between like the adopted
siblings was I don't know it took away
from the story for me I know it was sort
of the romance was the thing but I'm
kind of tired of romances I really like
the dynamic that you see between
siblings and I'm just so excited that
we're getting a brother and a sister
that's not oh I'm the older sister and
I'm doing whatever or I'm the older
brother and I'm guarding my little
sister they're twins they're the same
age and I really like the idea of sort
of the idea of sibling rivalry but also
but also working together like our two
brothers and I love the idea of like
sibling stuff so I almost cited about
let's point out that the
clip that you just saw was was not bad
I'm so sorry Oh God point out that work
that we didn't just see a hot nun Sister
kiss their adopted although a brother
and sister kiss would also not be new to
Assassin's Creed if we saw it there that
we that was seen a little yeah a little
incest before in this series that was
our no Annalise from unity with the
smoochy smoochy no but ya know I'm
really excited to finally have a leading
female assassin I think that raw hurrah
like that I got a lot of them one of my
hopes came true you got one of your home
that's your fondest wish uh and I know
oh by the way what you should tune in at
two o'clock to yeah I'm pacific time
because we have an episode of the lobby
um you'll talk a lot more about sort of
what you saw yep of Assassin's Creed
syndicate you'll be getting I'm sure
you'll be getting more into I almost set
a lease which would have been really no
easy another meaning meaning good I like
that name um and of course I'll pit
myself for just half a second because
i'll also be answering your questions
about the witcher 3 wild hunt so tune in
for that but also we saw the you know
there was there was one spot where where
she kind of saved Jacob Jacob right okay
Kevin language I'm single party fri um
but you saw the same way I'm use the the
rope lunch or whatever to like actually
the reply to get the get the revolver
out of love her the bloody Nora bloody
Nora I almost said bloody baron because
I've still got Witcher 3 in my head
you're so funny i love you but yeah just
right here what what the what's up with
the the Rope launcher so the Rope
launcher is the new weapon ubisoft
seemed the developer seemed really
excited about it and I was like okay is
it like a thing it's sort of functions
like Batman's grappling hook in the
Arkham games you can use it to surmount
buildings which we saw jacob shot it
upwards and he scaled the building much
much quicker you can in your assassin
gauntlet you can shoot the Housatonic
dirts from it the interesting thing
about the Rope launcher that I saw when
if you are standing on a roof
or anywhere you can shoot it to another
rooftop and you can zip line if it's
lower you can zip line down if it's
higher you can actually climb it across
and that turn you can attach it anywhere
and that Rope launcher makes all of the
airspace in Victorian London available
for aerial assassinations so you could
in theory do this stop halfway through
look down and assassinate the person
below you turn shoot the Rope launcher
back up and just Rope launcher right out
of there like it looks super cool launch
you're right you're right on out of
there no super it looks super cool and I
like that it gives you more more attack
options I love Assassin's Creed games
and I loved action-adventure games with
stealth in it that have the stealth
option but I am like I am a stealth
player I tried to stealth only stealth
through the last of us and just failed
miserably but i prefer against your
greed has never really been then just us
delft spy but i like that this is sort
of bringing it into a more modern
stealth approach than using stealth away
a lot of a lot of recent games use it
and i like that i have i have that
option that i can just sneak around and
i have a lot more options to do sneaky
kills right Oh Terry is great so I got
one more question for you that I have if
you know the answer which is about this
territory control thing yes I'm kind of
curious about that because like it
brings mines been like okay so
Assassin's Creed revelation had the
whole thing where I mean not only did
you capture capture places but they
powered offense yeah but then you had to
defend them and then I had that stupid
tower defense a minigame built in there
so well forget about the tower defense
mini game for a minute but I'm kind of
curious are you going to have to then
defend that are they are you know do you
know if they're if the gangs are going
to try to come in and you know take
control of the regions that you've
already taken for your own is there like
a tug-of-war so I know that like your
goal as Jacob and Evie is to tap the
Templars control the underbelly of
London as well as the not underbelly of
London but each borough will have a gang
leader that
you have to overthrow and you have to
capture their strongholds and like get
their men and bring them you like we saw
in the demo we are [ __ ] TV fry you
work for us now uh like okay like this
is inverted manners like oh okay sure
yeah and they're like of course the name
of their group by the way is the rooks
that's the name of course it is not
reverse it is there that rooks um and
you cannot these burrows and they're
yours there are seven burrows in London
and you have to get all of these
strongholds I don't actually know if you
if you then have to defend them I'd like
to know it'll be something interesting
to know for certain yeah I also want to
work the fact that it's the rooks so I
Robert for people that don't know
they're in Far Cry 3 there's actually an
island called rook island if you go to
Rock Island and far cry 3 there's
Assassin's Creed Easter eggs on that
island so it's not actual Easter eggs
it's not like you know right it's not
like you're going and hunting you know
for actual actual actually I can't
believe I'm explaining myself I'm still
tired as it anyway my stupid stuff here
so yeah that was assassinated in to get
former codenamed victory you can look at
my previews they're all up on gamespot
com right now i'll be talking more about
it on the lobby and thank you for
watching hey my pleasure
you